all right well turning now to a vision
for a very different future in the
american craft beer industry
right now only seven and a half percent
of brewers in the u.s
are women just two percent of all
breweries are all female owned
cbs this morning co-host cbs sporting
saturday co-host dana jacobson recently
visited an
all-female owned and operated brewery in
colorado in aurora
the brewers shared their ambitious plan
to turn a passion
into a movement dana good morning good
morning a lot of people don't realize
but women were often the ones brewing
beer in the united states until the late
1800s that's when beer turned into big
business and women were pushed out
nowadays there are breweries working to
change the male-dominated industry
including one we visited in colorado its
mission
brew great beer to make the world a
better place
this idea came from us having beers of
like a long night and
just kind of sitting there and
commiserating and then at the end of
that being like
beer fear is the solution to this we're
going to get the money we need from beer
betsy lay kate power and jen cuesta
love beer and its potential i think you
can just make it whatever you want to be
find a beer to everyone's taste
it's literally a liquid form of like
breaking bread with people
after serving together in americorps
they also realized
beer could help quench their desire to
keep
doing good in 2014 they created lady
justice brewing
with the goal of donating the majority
of their profit to groups in colorado
promoting opportunities for women and
girls
we feel this connection to women in our
lives who
have made a difference for us and then
another thing that i've learned over the
years is that women and girls are
actually
lower funded in grant projects and
fundraising projects so
it's just another way to make sure that
folks in marginalized communities get
some attention
the co-founders all get paychecks from
their day jobs two are public service
lawyers
that means most of the profits from lady
justice can go towards the cause
so far this year they've donated more
than 11 thousand dollars
this is our mash tun okay her name is
june carter mash
on the day we visited their year old tap
room betsy lay was brewing a lager in
the back
she starts adding 400 pounds of locally
malted farley
into this mashton she even let me stir
it in
it's a good lap workout yeah lay
and her co-founders have always brewed
most of their own beer
but that doesn't mean they haven't faced
skepticism
did you encounter anyone who was like
what do you mean three women are they're
opening
a beer place what are you talking about
the very first meeting i had
i told the person what our idea was and
they said oh
who's gonna brew your beer and i said
well we will and he said no but
who is going to be like your brewer and
i said no but me we
us we're going to brew the beer so there
was quite a bit of that still
they say they've been insulated and
didn't always realize how unique an
all-women-owned brewery truly is
it wasn't until i met women um
outside of denver in the industry at
conferences and different stuff would
just be like
i'm i'm so happy that you all exist and
i was like
what very cool yeah it was really a
unicorn moment where i was like all
right
you know jen is mexican-american and
we're all three women and i'm gay
and kate's left-handed i'm left-handed
it's a real struggle so we didn't know
that we were creating something that
didn't really exist before we had no
idea now though you do
yeah no no yeah
the beer industry came under fire in may
when a massachusetts brewer asked women
on instagram if they had experienced
sexism
the cascade of responses lit up the
industry
reaction from the heads of breweries was
swift
were you surprised by the social media
conversation
no sadly no what was happening there
showed that this problem is prevalent in
the industry
it's woven through it so there are
really large horrible events that have
happened to women assaults
that are really awful and then there is
also these daily
comments not being believed in your job
we need it out in the open and we need
to talk about it and it needs to stop
lady justice strives to be a space where
those conversations happen
and a space that honors female pioneers
the brewery's first beer was an ipa
named after sandra day o'connor
the first woman to serve on the u.s
supreme court
we were featured on a law blog and we
said oh we'd love
to have a beer called sandra day o
porter and a few weeks later we got an
email
and it said mom likes ipa
it was from scott o'connor and he said
hey
my mom saw your blog she's a big fan of
what you're doing and she'll give you
naming rights to the beer but she'd
really prefer not a porter she's more of
an ipa girl oh my gosh
um and from that moment on we were like
okay sandra day ipa
does it feel like you're having that
impact that you wanted to in the
beginning
i'm so proud of what lady ga has become
but i think we're just going to continue
to push it the goal is to generate as
much money that we can give away and i'm
proud of all of our partnerships with
the community
but is it enough no we're not there yet
and the founders are not just fans of
sandra day o'connor also fans of cbs
this morning and they are working on a
beer
inspired by gail hey yes they are
they're going to call it a
morning brews like morning news they
want to use your iconic yellow dress
that you
air that you wear obviously every year
they want to use that on that
can or that color i'm very serious it's
going to be a
pineapple mimosa and they're working on
this right now it sounds cool does it
have
no alcohol it has alcohol
i know that they're aware that that is
not your computer you don't
like it i don't know but they are but i
might drink
it i might take a sip of a gale burger
but pineapples um
mimosa sounds very friendly can you do a
beer that's not alcoholic
yeah oh yeah yeah i was just thinking
they were so cool watching them
they were so cool amazing their fans are
theirs now no no big fans yeah but i
like how when you asked were any of you
surprised and they all said no
at the same time right away because they
while it took them a while to realize
how special they were they've seen that
in the industry and they knew it was
only time before
others started asking why are women
having to deal with these issues
and i also like the part i know i love
the story i always liked the part where
they said well
who's going to brew it well we are no
but who's going to brew it right
who's going to automatically assumption
is that there must be nothing alcoholic
beer but i do so brilliantly we'll get
it
thank you very much dana i love that
thank you thank you guys thank you